Television is supposed to be entertainment.
And it's pretty deliciously entertaining when
TV writers try to predict the future.
Sometimes they don't even mean to, but TV
shows have called out world events long before
they've happened.
Here are eerie examples of some silly little
TV shows that somehow knew what was going
to happen before the rest of us...
Chris Rock knew O.J. did it...Before O.J.
Did
In the first moments of the very first episode
of The Chris Rock Show on HBO, Rock aired
a sketch about O.J. Simpson hawking a videotape
called "I Didn't Kill My Wife, But If I Did,
Here's How I'd Do It."
It brutally mocked Simpson, acquitted for
the murder of his ex-wife in 1995, but still
widely believed by the public to be guilty.
Amazingly, almost ten years later, Simpson
imitated that sketch in real life, with an
almost exact same title, when he penned his
book, If I Did It.
To promote it, he even taped a TV special
called If I Did It, Here's How it Happened.
Ultimately, good taste prevailed, and neither
were released.
Family Guy Predicts Caitlyn Jenner
In a brief, throwaway gag in an episode from
2009, baby Stewie Griffin casually tells Brian
the dog the truth about Bruce Jenner.
"Bruce Jenner is a woman.
An elegant, beautiful Dutch woman."
That was a full six years before Jenner announced
that she now identifies as a woman and goes
by Caitlyn Jenner.
As far as we know, she still isn't Dutch.
An X-Files Spinoff Envisions 9/11
In 2001, the conspiracy theorist characters
from The X-Files known as the Lone Gunmen
got their own short-lived series.
On the first episode, they uncovered a conspiracy
about the U.S. government planning to crash
an airplane into the World Trade Center, blame
it on foreigners, and then use the resultant
outcry to justify raising the defense budget.
Apart from real-life conspiracy theorists
who believe the U.S. government was behind
the events of 9/11, it’s chilling that a
TV show suggested the possibility of an airplane
flying into the Twin Towers only months before
it actually occurred.
Quantum Leap And The 1996 Super Bowl
In a 1990 episode of Quantum Leap, Sam quantum
leaped into the body of a high school football
player.
In keeping with the football theme of the
episode, Sam's holographic advisor Al mentions
that he's watching the tail end of the 1996
Super Bowl.
"I been watching Super Bowl 30.
Oh Sam the Steelers are down by 3 you wouldn't
believe-"
"Al this is the only game I care about."
That’s really how Super Bowl 30 in 1996
went down.
The Pittsburgh Steelers were in the game against
the Dallas Cowboys, and in the fourth quarter,
the team really was down by 3.
"Oh boy"
The Simpsons Called It: President Trump
The Simpsons has a lot of episodes set in
the future, but they’re usually just a vehicle
to make jokes about future technology.
For example, in an episode where Lisa is in
college, robots are common but they catch
fire and melt whenever they feel human emotion.
In the same episode, Lisa calls Marge with
video-phone technology.
And whilst we do have Skype and FaceTime,
we're still waiting for our melting robots.
So take what you will from this prediction,
first aired way back in 2000, when Lisa gets
elected president:
"As you know we've inherited quite a budget
crunch from President Trump."
It's possible!
After all, The Simpsons has correctly predicted
the actual outcomes of elections before...
"America!
Take a good look at your beloved candidates!
They're nothing but hideous space reptiles!"
(audience gasps)
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
prediction spooked you the most...